biden continued in that speech yesterday
and he's warning us you remember about
two months ago and for a month he warned
us that
there was going to be a war coming with
russia and ukraine now he's warning us
about food shortages here we go
nothing more to report with regard to
food shortage yes we did we
still talk about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real
the price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries in our country as
well
ah so the sanctions are going to cause
us and the europeans to have food
shortages um liz where we promised that
a couple weeks ago when this thing
started i don't remember anything about
food shortages right here at home i mean
we're shortage of we're having shortages
of everything else so i guess we should
have expected it but i don't remember
that
well i think there's a couple things i
mean i myself was waiting during this
speech for biden to mention whether um
his transportation secretary buda judge
was actually back to his job whether he
was going to address the supply chain
crisis that we've been experiencing that
does lead to food shortages the the
other reason this is true right everyone
who goes to a grocery store which means
not joe biden understands that prices
have been hiked really high i mean a
gallon of milk is a lot more expensive
um diapers i buy diapers for my daughter
they're a lot more expensive this is a
this is a real thing that we're dealing
with and the reason is it's not just
arbitrary it's not just happening it's
happening because of deliberate
political decisions that joe biden has
made whether it's spending which leads
to um inflation whether it's not
addressing the supply chain crisis
whether it's environmental policies that
have that have hurt our farmers across
the country that have either driven
prices up or driven the supply down this
is this is joe biden being out of touch
once again and i i'm excited in a sense
to see how this plays out in the
midterms because people are hurting and
he's just being flippant about it carol
i want to focus on one word that liz
said right there deliberate because all
week i did shows this whole week
basically my argument at this point is
that this is deliberate i think that
they actually do want these supply chain
issues i think they want food shortages
i think they want high gas prices they
are trying to usher in his words a new
world order and you'd have to collapse
the system and make everyone think this
thing doesn't work so so when people say
that oh no they're just bad at what they
do it's like no they're actually quite
good at it what do you think about that
i don't know i you know the problem with
that and i i get why that could be a
theory of what's happening because
everything makes no sense um but the
problem with that is at the end of that
who chooses like the biden
administration or democrats in general
to lead the way on this new world order
um
when this everything has collapsed
around them i think one of the things is
that we don't hear from joe biden that
often and when we do hear from them it's
always like winter of despair is coming
it's like
it's never like don't worry i'm gonna
make things better for everybody it's
always like prepare for the worst we're
all gonna die um so i i don't really
know why that's the strategy
that his cam you know his administration
has come up with for when we do see the
president he's always there to deliver
the worst possible news to us um i i
think food shortages are coming i don't
think they have anything to do with the
with the war in russia i think people
have been predicting these food
shortages for a while i think we're
seeing in stores uh a lack of supply it
it completely comes back to this
administration being inept and not
caring that this is affecting people on
a very day-to-day basis and it just
they're the world of you know the
delayed treadmill etc they have no idea
of what's really happening out there in
america yeah by the way congratulations
on to you guys for surviving the winter
of death and uh michael those had a
great point we went from like the winter
of death to now the spring of food
shortages it's just incredible the the
way they use fear but but that's pretty
much all they got at this point right
liz
yeah certainly i mean it's emotional
manipulation it's emotional blackmail i
think that the the threats for the
spring aren't going to be quite as
frightening to people as the threats of
covid but this is what they do i mean
think about how they act on climate
change they tell us in 11 years or i
guess it's 10 years but now you haven't
noticed that they changed their talking
points which is interesting they're
still saying 11 years three years in a
row in 11 years the world is going to
end if we don't if we don't stop eating
red meat and stop using airplanes and if
we don't sacrifice our souls on the
altar of socialism here they do the same
thing with covet if we don't give away
our freedoms then you will die and you
will be killing grandma now you know
you're not going to have food for your
family if you don't if you don't let let
the democrats turn our country into a
marxist state i mean at some at some
point they're gonna have adrenal burnout
syndrome i would think just from this
constant hyping um but i i don't know i
i would hope that the american people at
some point would realize listen these
predictions are not coming true these
predictions are inaccurate it is
fear-mongering and i i i do think it's a
deliberate strategy i do think that you
are correct when you say that it's a
deliberate strategy because in order to
usher in the america that they want or
the governing system of our country that
they want a socialist communist marxist
system they have to destroy our
institutions first this is classic
critical theory this is marxism um and
so they know that this is a part of
conditioning the public to do that carol
which would you say is worse if it's
deliberate or not deliberate which is
actually worse i mean if it's deliberate
then it feels like oh we can fight it
because we know there's something direct
to point at i mean if it's complete
ineptitude i'll play i'll pretend that
that sounds right like that's much
scarier in a way right
right well that's that's exactly it i i
i'm not sure which the conspiracy theory
is at this point but no i think it is an
ineptitude i think this administration
has no idea what's going on and and
they're just completely out of touch i
just i remember you know joe biden going
on vacation uh as the afghanistan thing
fell apart and it's just like how do you
do that how do you go home to delaware
when americans are dying in a country
that you know we've been in for so long
and you you pulled out haphazardly and
really um didn't care about them and so
i you know
liz said that amer who she hopes
americans see through what's going on
and i i really do think americans have
gotten very savvy and that they
understand a lot more than they stay
used to and they're able to see the
angles in a way that they hadn't maybe
in the past um i think they see this
administration for what it is i think
they they know that
things are going badly and it's the
direct result of this administration and
their policies whether or not that's
intentional is a separate issue but i
think americans really do know where
this begins and ends
i hope you are right